[Music]
i joined team indigenous to be a part of
something bigger than myself it's very
important that we have visibilities
native people i just think it's like
important to see somebody that looks
like you at the top level
this great big story is brought to you
by delta
when we venture out into the world we
see all that we share
[Applause]
i'm april fournier and i've been playing
roller derby for five years and i'm the
co-founder of team indigenous
team indigenous is a roller derby team
made up of indigenous athletes from all
across the world i think everything
looks good so we want to really trust
each other and trust ourselves
the lack of representation for
indigenous nations really
fueled the reason that we wanted to
develop this team and create this space
for other indigenous athletes to join
and compete against all of these other
nations because we are a nation nice
let's do that again
[Music]
i've played sports all my life and just
nothing ever
captured my attention as much as roller
derby living in maine no one else really
kind of understands what it's like to
kind of be the only person of color
skating on a team one day i saw a skater
that was on one of the best teams in the
world and she looked like me and
ultimately from that we came up with
team indigenous
[Music]
hey everybody
hope all is well so good to see you
having
teammates from canada all around the us
and south america the way that we're
able to communicate is through video
conferencing if you haven't seen any of
the updates our first game is against
team japan which is really exciting
team indigenous will be at rollercon
participating in the nations tournament
rollercon is a roller derby convention
in las vegas that is seminars on skate
training tournaments
it's just this really giant celebration
of the roller derby community
when i play roller derby being in that
pack being in that mix there's just no
other feeling like it there are so many
different
friends and skaters that look like me
they talk like me they have similar
life experiences
[Music]
team indigenous is absolutely not about
wins and losses it's about being able to
take the track together and see
your siblings and you're all
representing together on the track as
one
it's not something that you can quantify
it's not something that you can measure
it's just it's community it's nation
it's indigenous and that's what we are
[Music]
you